it has been reported
just a couple of places that what is
that something very very
bad is going on in louisville kentucky
so zach you can put up my screen and
actually keep it up while i
scroll through a couple of tabs the
louisville courier journal which is the
local newspaper
reported on um it was updated
uh yesterday was reported first on
august 1st
uh that the cuban community plans rally
at the nulu restaurant in response to
black lives matter demands
and some of you will have heard what
what this story is but
um basically this guy fernando martinez
uh who is
himself an immigrant from cuba and has
become successful as a restaurant
group in louisville uh basically
received what he described as mafia
tactics
shakedown requests uh from the local
black lives matter movement
uh and uh yeah they they were requiring
things like x percent of the purchases
be made from black owned businesses
and x percent of the employees be black
to reflect
uh the underlying demographics of of
louisville
and you know this this is sort of as we
have come to expect at least the two of
us and many of
many people watching from the
uh we would like to think the fringe
parts of the black lives matter movement
but
um of course this these sorts of things
are
described and to some degree celebrated
on the block on the official black lives
matter website so once again
black lives matter is not what it seems
just because it's wrapped up in a bow
with words that sound like words we all
should and need to be able to get behind
doesn't mean that it is what it claims
to be so the courier journal reported
this
and uh fox picked it up
and uh used you know added a little bit
of reporting but mostly i think just
picked up picked up the story so i we've
been looking at this story for a couple
days here's the uh
um here's martinez the cuban restaurant
owner
with a statement um and you'll rather
than focus on oh my god here they go
again here goes black lives matter again
i thought i just look i was actually
hopeful so this morning at 11 30 a.m
our times just about an hour ago i just
went to
five of the major media outlets and
searched on louisville figuring that
anything else might be too you know too
fringe but i just searched on louisville
so when i searched on louisville after
this story has been in the news
that we are seeing for three days the
new york times
um its last louisville story is from
two days before um the louisville paper
first published this and um
in which louisville was declaring racism
a public health crisis so nothing there
wapo the washington post um sorry my
computer crashed just before airing
um just uh four days before
uh is uh louisville receiving extension
to respond to ncaa allegations so
nothing there's something from longer
ago about the brianna taylor protest
nothing there cnn
again nothing we apparently have a polar
bear dying at a zoo
which you know it doesn't please me but
it has nothing to do with the actual
news that is coming out of louisville
uh here we have msnbc similarly
absolutely nothing about this story and
uh i went to time magazine as well and
again nothing so um that's just
i figure you could do this for almost
all of these stories and this was simple
because there was a city
where there have been protests there has
been action there has been reporting of
late
let's see if as soon as the narrative
switches
we get any play at all and apparently
the answer is no
so um i want to
take a little victory lap here for idw
style sense making because the story
clearly
reflects a pattern and i think
actually some of the uh demands were
even more onerous than the ones
uh that you reported yeah actually i
might be able to
don't switch to my thing here but um
you know uh non-profits in the newly
district will submit to a voluntary
external audit of their board of
trustees and take necessary steps
uh quarterly roundtable discussions to
be held accountable for their
commitments to these demands
all business owners and non-profit
leaders um
yeah and oh dr dress code policies
it the claim is dress code policies
inherently discriminate against black
folks women in the transgender community
you must eliminate dress code policies
and we will not waver while the black
community continues to be destroyed
so some of them um i would just like to
point out
you just went through a series of
mainstream
uh press outlets that fail to report the
story entirely
um earliest uh prediction of such a
thing i would say
is eric's coining of the term
intersectional
shakedown it goes back years yep
um i have argued that and of course his
gin
gated institutional narrative both of
those things right are resonant why
do you not see this because the gate has
closed and this narrative
um will not be breached by that
inconvenient fact
i have said that this movement is
interested in reparations
24 hours a day seven days a week 365
days a year
at every context in every scale every
interaction
right this is beginning to be that you
have pointed
to the proliferation
of things like black lives matter signs
in store windows that you have called uh
don't hurt me displays and i believe
that
michael tracy who to the point about
uh bridging divides with people michael
tracy who has tangled with
various people in the idw at various
points nonetheless put together
a report apparently where he goes
through he was on the ground here in
portland
and he released some very dramatic uh
video of him being
attacked by uh antifa members
but he apparently shows what you and i
know from being downtown here in
portland which is that there is
yes the protests were concentrated
around the federal buildings but there's
damage
extensive and there are many businesses
that effectively
plea not to be injured on the basis that
they
support black lives matter and so what
this all does
is a it makes it impossible to know
how much organic support there actually
is because there's a whole hell of a lot
of inorganic support that people
recognize that whether it's the question
of their personal reputations being
destroyed and their
livelihoods being wiped out or whether
it's the businesses that they have built
and their ability to continue to
function
in place you know we've seen years of
this kind of nonsense where you know
women were attacked for uh making
burritos while not being mexican and um
so anyway the point is and this and this
is all
uh directly predicted by the hovel essay
that i read from last time
exactly his green grocer his green
grocer who puts the sign
in in his window um so if you're paying
attention to the mainstream sites
you will have no idea that this is even
going on you will not understand that
your sense making is missing this very
important piece of information about
what this movement is and so
when you see people like us troubled by
the idea that this movement is
partnering with the democratic party and
what does that mean for the future of
the country
you'll think we're overreacting right
because you've been fed
a verificationist slate that will lead
you to believe that things aren't nearly
so troubling as they
actually are we are for instance to
believe that now the feds are out of
portland everything's fine
and of course what has happened is that
the uh
that the rioters have moved to the east
side of portland to
a local police precinct where they are
making trouble there they're no longer
in front of the federal building
um they have they've moved their
activities so all those going to the
federal building and looking for
confirmation
that it was the feds who were causing
this can find that that is the
verificationism in action
so it's like um willful blindness
using verificationism you will be
provided a set of evidence that is safe
for you to navigate and say i don't see
the problem
and it's uh it's very very dangerous
yeah
um i guess one final point i would make
is something emerged
i believe yesterday body cam footage
from the george floyd arrest
and i must say back when i was on
uh joe rogan's program last one when
would that have been
june maybe july june july somewhere
on the cusp of uh of the dawning of july
and i um one of the things i talked to
him about
was that the age of aquarius i'm not
sure
no that's a boomer thing i'm not into it
but um
anyway i talked to joe about the
troubling hints that the george floyd
arrest was
a very complex thing that would require
a court to sort out
the details which i still feel very
strange about saying
given what everybody seems to believe
about this arrest
in the intervening time a transcript
of the body cam footage emerged and i
read it as you did
and it is full of complexities that
reflect yes the need to actually sort
out
what the police policy was what the
state of george floyd was
lots of things including that he uh
insisted he couldn't breathe before he
ever hit the ground that he
actually um requested to be put on the
ground that he refused to be
put in the in the vehicle but in any
case the body cam footage emerged
yesterday and it does reflect the same
complexity that requires
um sorting this out in a court
but then today cnn
released an edit of that video which
seems to strongly suggest the
alternative interpretation that
everything is exactly as you've been
told it's just as dire as you think
so are you saying that what was released
yesterday is unedited that we have
access that was released by the police
department presumably is unedited do we
have reason to believe that that's true
i am saying that first of all i'm not
sure what unedited it means there's
obviously a start and a stop point and
you've got
between the start and stop point are we
seeing everything that was recorded um
that's a good question i'd like to know
the answer to it so an edit of an edit
is obviously devious but an edit of a
non-edit
is even is far more devious right and
here's what i would caution
our viewers i think you should see the
whole thing
and before you formulate a judgment on
what you've seen
you should look at all of it in context
if you assume
that cnn is presenting you with the
salient bits and you make
you formulated judgment based on that i
think you will come out somewhere
very different than you would come out
if you just simply looked at whatever it
is
that the body cams recorded as they were
operating
so um this
you know incredibly uncomfortable to
talk about this but the complexity
of what unfolds is substantial and
you should not let anybody tell you what
it means
the answer is this does require a court
and in order to have a court
that functions properly it requires that
citizens who sit in that court as
members of a jury
understand that they are entitled to
reason based on evidence rather than
based on the threat of violence that
clearly exists if the verdict does not
go the way the public expects and most
of the public
hopes it goes so um anyway
it's a caution about verificationism and
about the fact that the gated
institutional narrative
is inclined to deliver you something
that your verificationist mindset
is likely to accept and that this can
actually march us into
great danger of historical proportions
[Music]
you